Moi, avec mon ex,
on n'est plus ensemble, mais voilà,
on continue à se parler, on s'envoie
régulièrement des sms. Regardez !
Crève espèce d'ordure !
T'as gâché deux ans de ma vie !
T'façon, je t'ai jamais aimé !
Et un smiley immeuble.
Un vrai plaisir !
Je ne comprends pas les gens
qui restent amis avec leurs ex.
Tu peux pas tout dire à ton ex,
comme tu dirais tout à un ami.
Bon maintenant qu'on est juste amis,
je peux te le dire.
C'était trop marrant comment
tu faisais mal l'amour.
Ha ha ha, excellent !
Eh ben d'ailleurs, mon nouveau mec,
c'est un dieu vivant, lui.
C'est comme si tout ce que j'avais vécu avant
n'avait pas existé, tu vois.
Ah ouais, je vois très bien, ouais !
Ça me fait trop plaisir que tu te confies à moi !
Ben ouais, c'est cool.
>> Je me sens vraiment bien.
C'est bête à dire, mais moi,
ça me ferait trop chier
que ma nouvelle meuf soit plus complice
avec son ex qu'avec moi.
Donc je te présente Nico,
c'est mon ex,
mais tu peux aussi l'appeler
Patatou ! Ha ha ha !
Ou alors, ou alors,
tu peux l'appeler Biafine !
Ah non, pas ça !
>> Biafine ! Biafine !
Tu t'en rappelles ?
>> Oui, je m'en souviens, ha ha !
Et ça, c'est, c'est
>> Norman
C'est Norman, c'est mon... c'est mon...
>> Ton mec !
Bon, c'est mon mec.
Mais Patatou ! Ha ha ha !
Je sais pas, moi,
si j'avais une nouvelle meuf,
j'aimerais pas qu'elle soit
pote avec son ancien mec.
Je sais pas, y a toujours
forcément une petite ambiguïté.
Donc ça, c'est moi et Justine
au camping.
Là, on était au ski
à la montagne.
Et là, on était à la mer.
C'est qui le mec avec vous,
tout le temps ?
Ah ça, c'est son ex. Ils sont restés
super potes, t'inquiète !
D'accord.
>> Ils ont l'air bien potes, là, quand même !
Attends, non mais là, il la sodomise,
quand même !
Ouais, mais c'est amical.
Les filles, elles aiment pas trop
qu'on ait connu dix mille ex avant elle.
Tu vois, je peux comprendre.
Mais en même temps, quand t'as zéro expérience,
que t'as jamais rien vécu,
bah je sais pas, c'est
un peu moyen, quand même.
T'es forcément émotif
pour un rien.
En tout cas, ça me fait plaisir
d'être ta première expérience.
Il se passe quoi, là ?
Wouah !
Neurones, cellules, synapses,
y a un truc qui se passe, là !
Wouah ! Y a un truc qui se passe là !
Youhou ! Ok les mecs,
ce soir, c'est ma soirée !
Norman, mais qu'est-ce qui t'arrive ?
Ah non rien, excuse-moi,
c'est juste dans ma tête !
Moi, quand je suis
en couple avec une meuf—
Ouais, parce que je suis rarement
en couple avec un mec—
J'ai l'impression qu'elle veut toujours
tout savoir sur mes ex, sur mon passé,
pour avoir une relation
transparente et saine.
Mais moi, je trouve que c'est
justement pas très sain.
Je suis super contente
de passer une soirée avec tes potes.
Cool !
>> Mais j'aimerais bien qu'on soit transparents, tu vois ?
Donc s'il y a des filles avec qui tu as couché,
ben tu peux me le dire.
Ben, carrément ! Ben écoute,
bah y a Lucie, Sarah,
y a Mathilde — ça va ? —
Anaïs — ça va Anaïs, tranquille ?—
Y a moi aussi !
>> Ouais !
Voilà, y a Jessica, là-bas !
Non, non, mais c'est bon, en fait,
j'ai pas envie de savoir ! C'est bon !
Et Benoît !
C'est un jour où on se tapait un délire !
Moi, je trouve que toutes
les femmes sont belles.
Mais j'avoue que y a certaines ex à moi
que j'assume moins que d'autres.
Enfin, je veux dire, j'aimerai pas forcément
les recroiser avec des potes, quoi !
'Tain, il savait plus quoi dire,
le mec, ha ha ha !
Ah tiens, Norman,
ça fait longtemps, ça va ?
Ah salut, Josiane !
Je pensais pas te revoir un jour.
Bah alors, Norman, tu nous présentes pas ?
>> Ouais, c'est qui ?
Ah ben je suis son ex !
Ouais, une ex-amie,
une ex-amie.
Ben non, attends, on est quand même
sortis ensemble pendant deux ans, Norman !
Ha ha ha, que des vannes, alors elle,
toujours dans l'humour, la blague !
Ben, c'est pas une blague ! Regarde,
j'ai gardé une photo de nous en fond d'écran !
Ah, fais voir !
Ah merde !
Merde, il est tombé par terre,
je suis vraiment maladroit !
Bon, ben merci, Josiane, on se voit
une prochaine fois, on se rappelle.
Ben, je peux pas,
tu m'as bloquée !
Toujours des blagues,
toujours l'humour ! Le Coluche !
Moi, je déteste recroiser une ex
avec qui j'ai perdu contact.
Tu sais, j'ai l'impression d'être
dans une sorte de compétition cheloue
de qui à la meilleure
nouvelle vie.
Hé, Norman !
Ça va ?
Je te présente mon nouveau mec.
>> Salut !
Ah bah ouais, bah moi,
c'est ma nouvelle meuf.
Ouais, bah sauf que moi,
mon mec, il est hyper bien habillé.
Ah bah moi, c'est pareil,
elle est super féminine, très élégante.
Ouais, bah moi,
il a des gros muscles !
Ouais bah elle [pouet]
Ouais, elle a pas de muscle,
mais bon, elle est hyper sympa !
Ouais, bah lui, il a fait Sciences Po,
il a grave de la culture.
Bah moi, c'est une fille avec plein de trucs
de la culture, elle connaît les rois de France.
Les rois de France ?
>> Elle connaît tous les trucs.
>> Elle connaît les présidents et tout ?
Ah !
Merci de nous avoir présentés !
On a plein de points communs, c'est génial !
>> Je le kiffe déjà !
Avec plaisir !
Ah ouais, OK, donc...
Je t'offre un café ?
Tu te rappelles
comment je les aime ?
Laisse-moi réfléchir. Plutôt court,
avec un demi-sucre et une noisette de lait.
Un nuage de lait !
J'y arriverai jamais !
Ah ! Je peux te poser une question ?
>> Ouais ?
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire,
ce smiley immeuble ?
Merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo !
Si vous voulez venir me voir
sur scène, c'est possible.
Mon spectacle
"Noman sur scène"
continue cette fois-ci
dans tous les Zénith de France.
Moi, j'ai vraiment hâte
de vous voir en vrai.
Pour une fois, vous serez pas
que des vues ou des commentaires.
C'est ça qui est cool.
Donc, si vous voulez prendre votre place,
il y a un petit lien dans la description.
Merci à tous !
Danke schön !
Tchao !